[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo da sind wir wieder mit Tatort
Deutschland und einem verstörenden
Mordfall ich bin Mirko Kasimir und führe
euch mit Toni Hayer jetzt nach
Königswinter im Rhein-Sieg-Kreis in
Nordrhein-Westfalen hi Zusammen wir
schreiben den 14 Februar 2008
[Musik]
nach einem tödlichen Streit glaubt ein
Mann namens Gerd Paulus dass er den
perfekten Weg gefunden hat ein
Verbrechen zu vertuschen und zwar indem
er erzählt seine Frau sei aus seinem
Leben verschwunden warum diese Idee
erstmal plausibel erscheint das zeigt
die Statistik denn jedes Jahr werden in
Deutschland zwischen 70.000 und 90.000
Menschen als vermisst gemeldet insofern
ist es zunächst nicht unglaubwürdig wenn
man erzählt die Ehepartnerin habe sich
einfach davon gemacht theoretisch ja
aber halt auch nur theoretisch genau
Tony man sollte die Statistik auch zu
Ende lesen denn erfahrungsgemäß klären
sich etwa 50% der Vermissten Fälle
innerhalb der ersten Woche innerhalb
eines Monats liegt die erledigungsquote
bereits bei über 80% der Anteil der
Personen die länger als ein Jahr
vermisst werden bewegt sich bei nur etwa
3%, es ist also selten dass jemand
wirklich für immer vermisst bleibt
die Familie Paulus in Königswinter war
die Geschichte Teil eines skrupellosen
Lügen Gebildes und Ausgangspunkt ist am
besagten Februar Tag im Jahr 2008 ein
Streit Mirko
Familie Paulus lebt in Ittenbach einem
idyllischen Stadtteil von Königswinter
Vater Mutter Tochter und Sohn teilen
sich ein weißes Einfamilienhaus am Fuß
des Siebengebirges sie leisten sich die
Miete für das Haus obwohl Vater Gerd als
Gastronom immer wieder Schiffbruch
erleidet sich verschuldet sich
arbeitslos melden muss und tatsächlich
gibt es regelmäßig Streit zwischen Gerd
und Sigrid auch und vor allem um Geld
doch zu Handgreiflichkeiten kam es nicht
im Haus der Familie Paulus brauchst du
die Mutter auf gab der Vater schnell
klein bei berichtet der Sohn später
wörtlich er war immer ruhig nett
freundlich
am 14 Februar aber ist alles anders
morgens gibt es Streit dann verschwindet
Mutter Sigrid aus dem Leben ihrer
Familie das finde ich übrigens besonders
übel an dem Fall dass die Kinder einfach
von einem Tag auf den anderen ihre Mama
verlieren für mich wäre das der absolute
Horror die sind ja damals auch noch zur
Schule gegangen das Mädchen 15 Jahre alt
der Bruder 18 und die waren dann
komplett vor den Kopf gestoßen ja
wirklich übel Toni da hast recht Tochter
und Sohn sitzen damals schon auf der
Heimfahrt im Schulbus als sie der Vater
anruft sie sollen vorher aussteigen und
in einem Restaurant zu Mittagessen
an der Haltestelle wartet der Vater
allein auf sie Papa wo ist Mama fragt
die Tochter Christina Mama ist abgehauen
antwortet der Vater so erinnert sich die
längst erwachsene Tochter später in
einer Reportage des Magazins der
Süddeutschen Zeitung ihr Vater habe
weder außergewöhnlich traurig noch
aufgebracht
ich dachte sie dreht eine Runde ums Haus
sagt geht Paulus noch Jahre nach dem
Verschwinden seiner Frau gegenüber
Polizei und Öffentlichkeit die
Geschichte geht danach konsequent weiter
eiskalt Tage später erfindet der Vater
wieder eine Lüge die Mutter erzählt er
den Kindern sei zurückgekommen als in
der Schule waren zwei Männer mit einem
Lieferwagen hätten ihr dann geholfen
ihre Sachen vorzubringen später gehen
sogar noch Zahlungen von Sigrids Konto
an ihren Mann dafür fällt er die
Unterschrift seiner Frau auf dem
Überweisungsformular
auch auf dem Kindergeldantrag für seine
Tochter geht er so vor
ansonsten gibt es fortan keinerlei
Spuren mehr von Sigrid Paulus
sie nutzt weder ihre Krankenkassenkarte
noch hebt sie irgendwo Geld ab und sie
meldet sich nicht um
sz-reporter malte harwig rekonstruiert
in seiner Reportage 2015 in Wirklichkeit
verkauft der Vater heimlich die
Habseligkeiten der Mutter der Schmuck
geht an den Juwelier zurück ihr Handy
eine Damentasche und ein paar Schuhe
versteigert ihr bei Ebay
2009 dann ein Hoffnungsschimmer auf der
Polizeiwache teilt man der Familie mit
die Personalien einer Frau namens Sigrid
Paulus sein bei einer Verkehrskontrolle
in Düsseldorf aufgenommen worden doch
die Spur läuft ins Leere
2010 beginnt Gerd eine neue
Partnerschaft die Frau zieht zu ihm es
ist zum Rückblick perfide wie sich die
Familie entwickelt sind ich zumindest
die Tochter Christina resümiert der
Vater habe sich mehr um die Kinder
gekümmert vor allem um sie das sei ein
enges Vertrauensverhältnis geworden Gerd
Paulus sei 5 Jahre lang ohne wenn und
aber für Sie da gewesen sagt die Tochter
ganz anders als früher da habe der Vater
so viel gearbeitet dass er kaum Zeit für
die Familie hatte also Mirko dass sie
seine Nähe sucht verstehe ich ich meine
deine Mutter verlässt dich einfach ohne
auch nur Tschüss zu sagen wie muss ich
das anfühlen bitte und der Vater
unterstützt sie auch bei der
öffentlichen Suche nach Sigrid
Werbung kennt ihr das ihr bekommt eine
Schlagzeile aufs Handy zum Beispiel zum
Thema gasumlage und wisst nicht was das
jetzt bedeuten soll die Eilmeldung die
ihr dazu lest macht euch auch nicht
wirklich schlauer dann möchte ich euch
heute einen Podcast empfehlen und zwar
den neuen News Podcast die Informanten
mit Sally Lisa starken und warum heißt
der so ganz einfach sally ist eure neue
Informantin dreimal die Woche ordnet sie
das aktuelle News Geschehen für euch ein
und erklärt euch alle politischen
Hintergründe denn habt ihr euch auch
schon mal gefragt warum in Lutzerath
Kohle abgebaut wird obwohl die Grünen in
der Regierung sind oder warum
Abtreibungen in Deutschland immer noch
strafbar sind und das Gesetz dazu noch
nicht geändert wurde und was bedeuten
die Schlagzeilen von heute für mein
Leben sally ist frei Journalistin und
setzt sich für politische Aufklärung ein
in rund 20 Minuten erfahrt ihr von ihr
alles was ihr wissen müsst um mitreden
zu können und das ganz in Ruhe wie von
einer guten Freundin am kaffee-tisch
also setzt euch gerne dazu hört jetzt
rein und abonniert den Podcast jeden
Montag Mittwoch und Freitag gibt es eine
neue Folge in Podcast Player eures
Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
diese Suche macht rund um den
Jahreswechsel
2012/2013 Schlagzeilen Christina meldet
ihre Mutter offiziell als vermisst
wendet sich ein RTL und die Zeitung
Generalanzeiger dabei entsteht auch ein
Fernsehbericht mit einem weinenden Gerd
Paulus der schildert wie seine Frau
einfach verschwand und wie sie noch
zweimal kurz wiedergekommen sei um
Sachen abzuholen aber durch die
Vermisstenmeldung wird die Polizei
endlich aufmerksam hinsichtlich all der
Ungereimtheiten zum Beispiel auf das
Fehlen geht wieder Ummeldung bei Ämtern
als Aktenzeichen XY über den mysteriösen
Fall berichtet geht ein Foto von Sigrid
Paulus erneut durch die Presse dann geht
der entscheidende Hinweis ein Paulus
Ehemann habe im Garten umfangreiche
Baumaßnahmen eingeleitet der Fall steht
vor der Aufklärung im Oktober 2013 rückt
die Polizei in voller Besetzung zur
Hausdurchsuchung an
zu dieser Zeit wohnt Tochter Christina
wieder dort sie hatte zuvor geheiratet
und war ausgezogen jetzt aber hat sie
ihr Zimmer neben dem Weinkeller es ist
Tochter Christina die den Beamten die
Tür öffnet und sie reinlässt denn sie
ist allein zu Hause als später an diesem
Tag der Vater nach Hause kam so
berichtet ist die Kölnische Rundschau
nahm er die weinende Tochter wortlos in
den Arm in dem Moment war mir klar dass
die Polizei zu Recht da war sagt
Christina später kurz darauf führt Gerd
Paulus die Polizei dann in den Keller er
zeigt auf ein massives Weinregal dass er
im Eigenbau errichtet hatte
Spezialisten einer technischen
Polizeieinheit beseitigen das Regal und
stemmen den Boden auf
darin liegt Sigrid Paulus seit mehr als
fünf Jahren seit dem 14 Februar 2008 an
dem sie angeblich im Zorn gegangen war
der Fall Paulus ist gelöst
gelöst und trotzdem schwer zu verstehen
was ist in Gerd Paulus vorgegangen bei
der Tat und was in all den Jahren danach
im März 2014 wird ihm der Prozess
gemacht und jetzt endlich erfahren die
Kinder und die Öffentlichkeit was
passiert ist in königswinterittenbach
geht paulus sagt aus und gesteht der 14
Februar 2008 habe begonnen wie jeder Tag
die Kinder sind schon in der Schule die
Eltern begegnen sich am Vormittag im Bad
hier geht Sigrid Paulus ihren Mann wegen
seiner Arbeitslosigkeit und der
Finanzmisere an
als sie ihn schubste schubste er zurück
und als sie stürzte und ihn nun an den
Armen packte und anschrie sei es zu
einer affektiven Entladung gekommen nun
reicht es ihm fast ist der Richter
Jansen später bei der Urteilsbegründung
zusammen
er konnte es nicht mehr aushalten und er
wollte es auch nicht mehr aushalten er
wollte endlich Ruhe er packte sie am
Hals und drückte zu bis sie tot war
der Gerichtsmediziner stellt fest dass
Gerd P den Hals seiner Frau so brutal
zudrückte dass sie ihr dabei den
Kehlkopf zerquetschte nachdem der
Angeschuldigte keinerlei körperliche
Reaktion mehr wahrgenommen hatte so
vermerkt das Gerichtsprotokoll fühlte er
nach ihrem Puls und verblieb ohne einen
Notarzt oder die Polizei zu verständigen
nach seinen Angaben noch etwa 30 Minuten
im Badezimmer und überlegte wie er den
leblosen Körper verschwinden lassen
könnte
das sind so krasse Schilderungen
wirklich Gänsehaut gerade kein Wunder
auch dass eine der Schwestern von Sigrid
im Gerichtssaal Atemnot bekommt und
rausgebracht werden musste und ich meine
auch Tochter Christina verfolgt den
Prozess und das Urteil und hat sich das
alles an finde ich wirklich ganz ganz
hart Richter Jansen so wird es im
Brunner Generalanzeiger protokolliert
fragt welche Strafe wird der Tat und vor
allem denen die damit leben müssen
gerecht denn Sigrid Paulus sei tot und
nichts aber auch gar nichts macht sie
wieder lebendig
für den Angeklagten Sprecher sein
Geständnis und dass es eine spontan Tat
gewesen sei gegen ihn aber die Art der
Tötung erwürgen ist für das Opfer eine
schlimme Art zu sterben weil es so lange
dauert deshalb halte das Gericht 8 Jahre
Haft für angemessen
8 Jahre Haft bevor Gerd Paulus in
Handschellen aus dem Saal gebracht wird
blickt er in den Zuschauerraum wo seine
Tochter Christina sitzt das finde ich
wirklich das heftige sie hat nicht nur
die Mutter sondern in diesem Moment auch
ihren Vater verloren weißt du Toni es
ist vielleicht noch irgendwie erklärbar
ohne dass ich jetzt sage dass ich dafür
Verständnis habe dass jemand immer
Effekt eine andere Person umbringt und
danach ganz hektisch überlegt wie man
mit dem angerichteten davon kommt aber
jahrelang so ein Lügengebilde aufrecht
zu halten das ist irgendwie schon echt
krass besonders gegenüber den eigenen
Kindern die im Glauben zu lassen dass
sich die eigene Mutter nicht mehr für
die Familie interessiert das finde ich
wirklich perfide
er hat offensichtlich schon kurz nach
der Tat Pläne geschmiedet welche Lügen
er seinen Kindern auftischt und
natürlich auch wieder die Leiche
entsorgt im eigenen Keller da ist er
echt eiskalt geblieben und ich muss
sagen das schockierende daran finde ich
dass er seine Kinder so lange anlügt
ohne scheinbar ein schlechtes Gewissen
dabei zu haben also gerade die Kinder in
ihrer Verzweiflung die denken ihre
Mutter hat sie verlassen ohne Tschüss zu
sagen die bauen auf dich die Vertrauen
dir wie kann man da bitte jeden Abend in
den Spiegel gucken wenn du selbst die
Wahrheit kennst also da hätte ich schon
längst gebeichtet und gestanden aber
klar dann kannst du für deine Kinder
halt auch nicht mehr da sein der Toni
ich habe übrigens bei der Recherche
gesehen dass der Fall noch ein Nachspiel
hatte aber eher so eins aus der
Kategorie Tatortreiniger bitte was ja
das Haus in Königswinter hatte die
Familie Paulus ja gemietet und nach der
Aufklärung des Falls verklagte
Besitzerin das Land Nordrhein-Westfalen
denn die Polizei habe die Arbeiten im
Keller so unsachgemäß durchgeführt dass
der Leichengeruch durch das ganze Haus
gezogen und geblieben sei oh nee das ist
ja der absolute Albtraum die Klägerin
machte dabei geltend dass sie das Haus
habe umfassend renovieren müssen tja
Häuser kann man renovieren aber was wird
aus dem Menschen die von solchen Fällen
aus der Bahn geworfen werden mich hat
diese Geschichte im SZ-Magazin
beeindruckt denn Tochter und Vater haben
sich sogar noch geschrieben Christina
wollte z.B wissen was die Lieblingsfarbe
ihrer Mutter war und solche Dinge und
Gerd beantwortet das und schreibt ich
habe deine Mutter geliebt als ich sie
geheiratet habe und ich habe sie geliebt
bis über meine Tat hinaus und so gibt es
eben einen großen Unterschied zwischen
einer vermissten Meldung und dem Umstand
dass man jemanden für immer vermisst
eine Leiche im Keller das war wirklich
harte Kost fürs Herz die mich Mirko
wahnsinnig sauber macht wir danken euch
fürs zuhören und schaltet auch morgen
wieder ein wenn es heißt Tatort
Deutschland daily euer Mirko und eure
Toni den Fall Sigrid Paulus haben wir
mit Hilfe von Artikeln des Kölner
Stadtanzeigers Generalanzeiger und
Rundschau online nacherzählt Redaktion
und Skript Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die weight watch
Studios